bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono parigi in lui
e gian
e oggi siamo tornati sui lati episodio
di ricordiamo un po quanto era bella la
nostra infanzia visto che mi è piaciuto
così tanto il primo video lo sappiamo
realtà non era montato che abbiamo
deciso di fare questo episodio insieme
perché comunque siamo entrambi degli
anni 90 e ci ricordiamo insomma cose nel
nostro passato che hanno segnato la
nostra infanzia quindi andiamo a pescare
a commentare insieme le cose che hanno
decorato un punto nostra giovinezza che
non abbiamo più li conosce qualcosa di
questi è che oltre addirittura cover are
la quale di questi prodi o che mai
stessi sì sì sì tu che cosa hai o anche
jesse mccartney pure consolidare ancora
di montare ma pirati e meraviglia cosa
fa allora allora questo io ti dico la
mia da anche parleremo le magie 5 maggio
per questa gonna immaginatele non rosea
ma nere sei ok paride quando va ad
achille si fa a dire che questa
industria non era uomo nero marrone
marrone scuro marrone scuro invece
agamennone quando vai a [ __ ] dice noemi
apriamoli dice ma [ __ ] allora
allora quelli che sono a marola brividi
sicilia si è ancora tale perché perché
c'è una cosa dice questo dove troveranno
a questi mesi questa è una presenza
questi quatto li trovavi nelle merendine
a matrioska in cui nello scorso episodio
fatto vedere questo o questo questi te
li ricordi
no sono se stessi siano in realtà sempre
prima che quindi adesso mi spieghi chi
ha avuto l'idea di mettere le brioche di
fare del marchio con dei b b da mille
limon di uno si è seduta ha detto
facciamo dei bidoni per i bambini
facciamoli della fattura
non c'erano con la bacia erano veramente
poi tema perché se dovessi brandizzare
una cosa facciamo trovare le brioche
bidone dell'immondizia con la fascia
meravigliosa la mia vecchia proprio la
mia maestra delle elementari veniva
dalla sicilia e ci hanno portato un
pezzo di lava dell'etna grant e viene al
coperto 19 gen nove già perché ad un
pezzo così di lava del magma
solidificato una roccia e io ero andato
lì la posso spaccato un pezzo nero presa
dal omesso di dentro che c'è un pezzo di
sicilia
beh no allora però ecco allora io avevo
per uscire di un balcone c'era l'infisso
diciamo era calamitato ok io vedevo
tutto il balcone il pieno di questi cosi
la cosa più bella per me era il mio cell
a richard lee detto prima di uscire dal
balcone che guardava facevo 6 problemi
sono più nuove tabelle cicciottello del
mese rispetto alla gente si fida a me
adesso è questa la storia immagini che
vuoi sentire ribadire quello che stavo
per cantare stavo per cava virgola sono
un gattino sono la stella del tuo
telefonino senza parentesi chissà chi è
se non rispondi questo non lo saprei mai
e noi abbiamo il bellissimo perché
allora il tempo a me non piaceva il
wrestling pedali iniziato a seguirmi e
delle figurine del wrestling tra cui i
nostri preferiti e che invece non sia e
di carrè rohri mysterio l'unzione
quaderno
d'annunzio contro battista mi sembrava
io contro il mio cugino di 30 anni
o ancora bloccato il pieno grazie
potremo farci un'idea che non saprei
neanche cosa si troppi ricordi msn plus
che poteva modificati i colori certo chi
aveva incoronato ci avevano ovviamente
il trillo il trillo che certi tutte le
cose poter inviare la mia prima
fidanzatina e le ho chiesto di metterci
assieme su msn e l'immediato un
pezzettino il ritornello di attaché di
fioramonti lo rinominato con po sorpresa
glielo inviato detto ascoltano mi ha
detto di no provvedo perché non debba
definire allora allora qua parliamo di
un problema che l'italia a non questo è
vero non ci sono più e non va bene anche
perché da temere subito una volta meno
messo a piangere perché avevo trovato lo
stesso a con dentro al pacchetto lo
stesso con il pacchetto prima però di
calore hanno pianto ero piccolo ci sono
problemi di belle bambina massima punto
pilato raggiunti matematica e se anche
voi basta sei bello e poi erano altresì
titolo peschiera con queste lettere sì
no sì c'è un'altra roba per ora comunque
non scrivete sulle calcolatrici utilizzo
delle calcolatrici per questo motivo di
scrivere con quelle scientifiche perché
ci sono anche le parentesi molto bisogno
di moto e ancora meglio se volete fare
proprio questo si è evoluto nel livello
pro è questo
[Musica]
[Risate]
allora tu lo guardavi smallville
io lo so lo guardavi stai scherzando
la gente che vi faccio vedere come ma ti
ricordi come chi sono provati bellissimo
è bellissimo tra l'altro tra l'altro
l'attore che al tempo faceva simondi il
merito come si chiama adesso anche
partecipato in episodi del crossover di
superman massimi di camola c'è proprio
questa cosa per le sue celle xmm newton
che va indietro nel tempo incontro a lui
dice tu sei vero superman giudici
bellissimo ma certo non è come fai a non
aver visto bellissima realissimo
qualcuno mi sa mai ma questo era
incredibile io non ho perché non mi davo
pane anche adesso però quando mettevi la
roba nella radio esatto mamma non
soltanto questi ce l'avevo per qualsiasi
cosa capita non c'era la playlist
festivalbar e canzoni che cita avessero
sentito in tv come figurine mezzo trova
anche rim mysterio si è gente d'oro ma
vabbè madonna bellissimo allora questo
che stiamo parlando
mamma mia che dite che sogno erotico di
dossena manhwa opel
i pomeriggi persone 4
ah ok per ora le due e mezza di domani
sera hercules esatto delle persone
episodio crossover c bellissima che è
roba
mamma mia [ __ ] infinity ward aspetto
lui anche a me non piace super eroe
maledetto lui ma queste date alla aperta
solo per vedere se li conoscevo qualcosa
è l'unica cosa dei maggiori di questi al
frolli nemmeno girella ma si può che rob
è poca roba
però io la girella anche solo il vero
ciccione dentro la girella era l'unico
il giro si valuta una difesa invece
questa invece questa era la brioche bis
molecola ta del mondo si era la prende
ma anche solo prendendola in mano era
già lotta e comunque igor all
io ho roll o però un flauto nel cloud di
una sottomarca di barbiana next abbiamo
dei driver si parla di flauti e questo
era il flauto la yamaha ha fatto un
sacco di soldi non con le moto non un
riso adesso con i flauti delle armi e
delle obbligatorie a scuola ero nello
stile
il marito o 10 euro fine meraviglia
dormivano sempre di soffrire o
prostitute sulla cover in pelle questa
catalani infatti davies aveva in musica
due perché debt ceiling quel basso è
fortissimo e quindi questo era il
secondo video forse anche meglio del
primo
spero che vi sia piaciuto potenziare
sulle terre che un'altra bisogno insomma
di che ne saranno i 2000 ringraziamo
anche la pagina ovviamente che rimette
sempre queste cose noi ci crediamo non
posso leader vado ascoltarmi sigle di
cristina arrivo posso mettere anche
giorgio vanni giorno
[Musica]